talk a little about pinocchio first
ollie pinocchio was the second feature
it followed snow white
well when
walt started on that why
they were going to follow the book
and in the book by
pinocchio squashes the cricket
which
would have
i'll forgive you
how do you take a pencil
on one drawing at a time make a
character think
well you have to have some business that
somebody as smart as a walt has worked
out that's the big thing if you get
business that doesn't require
thinking or
good personality relationships why
you're in trouble
and of course i think that's why walt
became
on snow white and through all that whole
picture he was everything had to be
better than something that had been done
before and he kept improving everything
in the picture as he went along
and the same thing with pinocchio we
started out with a little wooden head
little boy with a wooden head
and ended up with
a
little boy in effect
but it seemed to play better to the
public and
i think he was right in what he did
did you always feel like a student
learning about animation every time we
were in a meeting with him where he
would talk about
the story and how he was improving
something while you try to grasp his
ideas and build on that and and try to
get your characters to have the same
type of life that he was looking for
it's not easy to get that and it's not
easy to talk about it
the way he did
it just
it was part of him and he he became
well he was such a great entertainer
it's a big thing
and
it was
just in him to make everything better
and keep making it better until you ran
out of money
now frank when you worked on bambi i
know that there was a little mini zoo at
the studio it was too hard to draw a
real deer
a real skunk they had real skunks too
they kept them out on the back porch
and uh
you couldn't draw them
the way you would like to animate them
so you'd keep sort of pushing that aside
and working on the animation of it and i
found out that
your best
model was what was on film
and if you would get some bottles some
film that'd been taken of a deer out in
the woods
and jumping over things and running
around stopping and looking back and all
the things stupid things that deer do
yeah the animators too i guess
but i learned more from studying the
film than i did from slitting the actual
animal on those deer he did not like the
long muzzle
and so he'd tell us now when that deer
has something to say be sure it's behind
a bush
and
he did he thought it was it was okay on
bambi because you made those features so
that they are kind of cute
but on the
grown deer and when bambi
he goes back and finds his father after
the mother's been shot why he said now
we got to have this all
a mist so you don't see this guy talking
when i look at the three caballeros
scene and i see some of the stuff some
of the crazy stuff
you do and you're doing that that was
really
that was really revolutionary at the
disney studio especially wasn't it yes
uh
i played the tune they'd already
recorded it
and uh and it made me mad because they
didn't have a storyboard or anything
so i decided to
do break all the rules of animation
and uh
it i don't
know how to say it
but it was i look back out and it was
the most fun i ever had